John starts off this hour in Buffalo New
York hey John and welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hi Dave thank you I have a
quick story and then a question for you
so I'm in college now just graduated
high school a few a couple of years ago
so when I was little my parents who are
now divorced started a business and
right after they were divorced it
exploded it made one hundred and fifty
eight million dollars in just a few
months whoa and my dad made fifteen from
that gave my mom one 15 years later
shoot Ford and we're all struggling and
it seems like the money's gone and he
wants me to get a Pell Grant and you
know now I haven't had to look for
scholarships which I'm fine doing but
I'm not fine without it's all gone so I
don't know how to talk to him about this
okay so you're how old at 20 okay and
you're in college yeah and well and he
lost 50 lost 168 million dollars well he
first it was that's what the whole
infomercial made so he made 15 for me I
don't know what oh he made 15 million
dollars how many years ago about 15
years ago okay around and and he gave
your mom 1 million dollars in the
divorce I boot in the day were partners
sort of so he gave her one and I believe
he gave it to her and made another came
from him more than 168 but I think it
was came from his okay all right and so
he had somewhere around 15 million and
she had somewhere around a million right
and I'd have half of that went to taxes
and so she had five hundred thousand and
he had 780 I'm sorry
that's for taxes sorry for interrupting
oh that's after tax yeah after income
tax yeah okay yeah and so over 15 years
he squandered fifteen million dollars
yeah or so he says yeah and you know
really you really I think by the way you
presented this you don't believe him
I do believe him he did tell me that
he's in the worst position he
ever been in and yaks like I mean he
could be lying I mean he could be and so
if the money is truly gone and you
believe the money is truly gone um what
does it matter you still got to get a
Pell Grant you still got to go take an
extra job and you you know work your way
through school you're still going to
have to choose a an inexpensive school
to go to to keep from going into student
loan debt right right right right that's
not going to change regardless of his
answer of why or rare right okay so I
don't guess it matters I love that Ezra
I mean it's not it's not it's a sad
thing and it might be a thing you know
over a cup of coffee someday with your
dad man-to-man rather than son to father
that's mad about my college and money in
here because you screwed up but aside
from that which is a valid thing by the
way it's okay for you to be a little
pissed off about that because the guys
really screwed up obviously but you know
it would be an interesting thing and I
would enjoy it myself is to say just to
have a cup of coffee with a guy that
does that and go okay what happened I
got to hear this story you know and and
you know come at it from that angle but
it's not going to change your situation
right and so I think as much as anything
you're you and you're very disappointed
that it left you hung out to dry and
that's a reasonable disappointment by
the way I don't think you're being
unreasonable to be disappointed in that
but to go in and you know kind of I
guess be angry and go where'd it go I
mean come on you leave me hanging out
here that day that's just not gonna do
any good it's not gonna help you right
and it's certainly not gonna help him
but I would I would love to have the
conversation someday once you kind of
get the other side of the emotions and
just say you know I'm just curious what
happened this has got to be a great
story it's got to be a 15 million dollar
story yeah right you know it's got to be
a story worth learning from you know the
book start that we sell one
the things we talk about there is the
idea that some people are all people are
mentors and some people are just a
lighthouse to keep you off the rocks
meaning you don't want to go where
they've gone and so yeah I'd like to
learn from him as a cautionary tale as
to how to not live my life right but uh
but I would love to hear the story but
but if he's in the middle of shame and
guilt and feeling bad and beat up right
now he's probably not in the condition
to tell the story right now okay so I
think if I'm you I'm going to focus on
my energy on you getting into the right
school that you can afford and then you
can pay cash for get the Pell grants
he'll have to sign up for all that
you'll have to get the income
information from him if he's who's
responsible and your mom blew a half
million dollars as well right one yeah a
one because it was after-tax yeah she
blew and she blew a million bucks -
right right so and they're struggling
now that my mom has no income and my dad
is very little but they're split up
right yeah yeah but that was how long
ago fifteen years
uh yeah I'm 15 so 15 years your mom
never got her act together
uh yeah I mean do they blame it on the
recession okay she does it me
all right there's a cautionary tale in
this whole thing for you as a young man
mm-hmm
and sometimes our parents teach us
wonderful things and sometimes they
teach us what not to do by the way they
did it and almost all of us that our
parents do some of both so you're going
to learn some things from your mom and
dad on how not to do life and and you're
going to I'm sure there's some good
lessons from them too I'm sure they're
not a hundred percent bad people but but
you certainly have outlined a couple
things here that they don't you don't
want to track in you don't want to
follow in that line so hang on the line
I'm going to send you a copy of the book
the Total Money Makeover I'm also going
to send you a copy of the book start
which will be helpful to you in this
situation and that we were just quoting
from and I think you'll enjoy it
hey thanks for the call
you